legend has it one day a new king will
come
who will use the power of the Trident to
put Atlantis back together one can
is the exact spot that Volkl gave me my
first woman lesson no not even close you
have to forget all the teaching of the
surface world go deeper one covering
your Atlantean instincts he spent his
entire life training
learning to be the best
my parents made me what I am
I am the protector of the deep
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis in their own hands it won't
bring destruction but in the hands of
the true heir it would unite above and
below the time has come for Atlantis to
rise again
must stop him about he proposed me mm by
retrieving this early Elmo's not like
this one you don't the war is coming to
the surface whether you like it or not
my mother always knew you were special
[Music]
you believe
you'd be the one to unite out to war
[Music]
he's always had a key
now I need something more
a wall could be greater than a king
here
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got our
final official aquaman trailer to break
down with a whole bunch of new footage
and some clarifications on the hold
MacGuffin of the actual trident and
what's happening during that final big
battle they actually do have a genuine
Kraken so we got to break it down
there's a new round of that IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this the music is better it
actually sounds like a genuine
soundtrack that might be one of his
heroes themes that they play through the
movie I don't know what the official
soundtrack is gonna be usually those
drop before the movie hits theaters so
you'll be able to listen to it on
Spotify but it actually sounds a lot
more solid the way that they cut this
trailer together is also a lot better
than all the other previous trailers so
just starting at the beginning of this
you get a slightly different version of
that intro of his origin story as a baby
where his mother is telling him the myth
about the one true king that will come
someday use the Trident to remake
Atlantis to bring everything back
together but the whole thing about
prophecy is that it's usually
misinterpreted by different people so
you probably have ormm
ocean master who grew up hearing that
same myth in thinking that it meant
something different uniting the seven
different kingdoms of Atlantis against
the surface world in the twist of the
trailer they already tell you upfront
that he's supposed to bring the surface
world together with the world of
Atlantis because they're one in the same
Atlanteans everybody that lives in those
seven different kingdoms even though
their genetics seem very different now
share common ancestry with the regular
humans above the ocean you even see they
have a dog in the background they better
not kill that dog when the Atlantean
guard come to take his mother back to
Atlantis I think what they're trying to
tell you and this is is that she has
Arthur then she's forced to go back and
they force her because she's Queen to
marry another Atlantean and then has a
son with that person that becomes ocean
master so I think that he'll wind up
being a little bit younger than Arthur
during the movie so you could say he has
a stronger claim but it just depends on
how you interpret their rules of
succession
obviously not super important in the
grand scheme of the movie because
they're actually doing trial by combat
game of Thrones style to battle for the
throne my brother has come to challenge
me and there are a whole bunch of scenes
during this fight that foreshadow the
giant lava Kraken that you see later in
the trailer look at them fighting here
you see all this magma below them in
this pit you see ocean master try to
throw
with his Trident later in the trailer
you hear ocean master say the Beast has
awakened I think he's talking about this
giant beast that's rising out of the
underwater volcano but they're not
totally clear on what winds up waking
the Kraken if it has something to do
with the Trident itself but I definitely
think the Trident is key to controlling
it
because when volcko unfurls this little
map and he's like how are we gonna save
the day and he says with this oh yeah
one of those I already got one of those
tridents that's actually a pretty funny
moment because he still has his mother's
Quinn dent that's the one that his
mother was using in all these fight
scenes in the flashbacks but they're
foreshadowing some big twist when they
say that this trident holds the entire
power of Atlantis that's probably a
metaphor the power that they speak of
probably goes just beyond normal energy
based power that you would think about
in a weapon speaking of which you
actually get to see a couple of these
people using their powers you see meera
using her hydro Kinesis it's way better
than what we saw during Justice League I
do like the way that they polish the
special effects in this and obviously
there's a whole bunch of chase scenes
with them flying all through Atlantis's
structures that looks way better than
the earlier trailers they're just a
function of them almost being done with
the special effects like they'll be
polishing that right up until the last
minute but for the most part this is
what it'll look like in theaters you
finally see a more graphical looking
version of Aquaman using his ability to
communicate with undersea life so you
see these waves coming out
this is him using his power whereas in
previous trailers you have like little
kid Aquaman holding his hand up and
that's all you sense the reason for them
doing stuff like this is just to
distinguish between when he's actively
trying to communicate or a call for help
and when he's just looking around but
it'll be interesting to see how his
powers function when he's wielding the
Trident and when he's trying to defeat
this giant Kraken beasts when they
talked about putting Atlantis back
together and you see the rocks on this
statue form again it's kind of hard to
tell if this is just gonna be an
explainer where they're visualizing
something or if this is something that's
actually happening in the real world of
the movie we get way more volcko in this
trailer that we've gotten in previous
ones he's been in every single trailer
but sometimes you can't really spot him
because he's in the background but you
do get a sense for how he helped to
raise him and train him when he was a
teenager even though we've already
gotten a version of his origin story
we've seen him in Justice League this
movie has to address that period in his
life so there will be some sort of
cussed
mery superhero montage where they're
testing their powers out for the first
time you see him open his eyes deep
underwater and all sudden everything
lights up like he's seeing with his true
eyes for the first time it's a good way
of showing you how much more powerful he
is when he's in water still extremely
strong extremely resilient when he's
above water but when he's in water he's
almost as powerful as Superman if not as
powerful when you consider that he can
control all the aquatic life I think
based on the way they've kind of set
these characters up Superman will always
be viewed as the most powerful person in
the DC movie universe with Wonder Woman
just under him then you have Aquaman
right at about the same level then you
have everybody else there's this wicked
shot of ocean master in his armor that
looks super polished but this blade
device behind them just looks so wicked
that it's hard to tell if it's a legit
propeller or if it's just some sort of
underwater giant drill or a weapon of
some sort in speaking of weapons when
they talk about uniting the surface
world with the world underwater there's
that voice over dialogue they also show
footage of Black Manta looking like he's
meeting ocean masters special ops team
for the first time you see that look on
his face he doesn't have any of his gear
on but it seems like what's happened
here is that some larger giant Atlantean
vessel has either forced his ship up
above water so that he can actually
communicate with them so that he can
talk to him for the first time the look
on his face makes it seem like he's
right about to crap his pants like he
has no idea what's going on so this is
probably before he meets ocean master
for the first time and gets his special
comic book armor but in related news
there's a whole bunch of Marvel stuff
happening there's a rumor that the
Avengers for teaser trailer is gonna
drop on Friday I don't know if that's
true if I hear anything more about that
I'll let you guys know but obviously
Friday is only a couple days away so
we'll find out really soon one way or
the other
congratulations math guy 64 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here for the special new
Deadpool Christmas movie trailer and
click here for a whole bunch more
Aquaman footage thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]